cette belle époque où les réseaux
sociaux était sûr que le coronavirus
était duhaupas gaulle 1 et supprimer
tous les contenus qu'ils disent l
inverse
maintenant ils sont plus si sûr
à la lumière des enquêtes en cours sur
l'origine du coc vite 19 et après
consultation d'experts en santé publique
nous ne supprimerons plus de nos
applications l'allégation selon laquelle
le kobe 19 a été mise au point par
l'homme nous continuons de travailler
avec des experts sur la nature de la
pandémie et nous mettons régulièrement à
jour nos politiques et ceux à mesure que
de nouveaux faits et de nouvelles
tendances apparaissent c'est le chef de
la ms lui même qui a rétropédalé sur la
question il y a eu très tôt une tendance
consistant à minorer l'une des possibles
aux origines du coc vite 19 à savoir
celle de la théorie du laboratoire comme
vous le savez j'ai moi-même été
technicien de laboratoire
je suis immunologue j'ai travaillé en
labo et les accidents au laboratoire
arrive ces mêmes fréquences mais cela
reste en fait durant plus d'un an les
grands réseaux sociaux ont écrit
l'histoire officielle
quant à l'origine du courant d'un virus
maintenant et s'occupe des vaccins est
selon le président américain joe biden
et son administration il ne faut pas un
très bon boulot
quel est le message que vous voulez
envoyer aux plateformes comme facebook
ils tuent les gens
la seule pandémie à laquelle nous devons
faire face c'est celle des non vaccinés
nous avons intensifié les recherches sur
la désinformation ainsi que sont suivis
avec le bureau du chef de service de la
santé et nous signalons les publications
problématique sur facebook facebook
important supprimer plus de 18 millions
d'informations et on est sûr locaux
vides et les comptes qui enfreignaient
les règles à plusieurs reprises mais
apparemment à tous sur le segment russe
de facebook d'instagram des comptes
propageant des informations disons très
peu vérifier fleurissent sans problème
toutes les personnes vaccinées mourront
d'ici à deux ans le covin n'existe pas
les scientifiques du monde entier ont
déjà prouvé que les gens souffrait de
pneumonie chimiques ce qui est une
conséquence d'un empoisonnement de l'air
on disperse du fluor de béryllium et du
dioxyde d'azoté depuis des avions
vous comprenez que rien n'est aussi
simple ce qui se passe c'est une
intimidation mondiale de la population
avec le virus pour les faire vacciner et
mettre des puces à tout le monde
la pétition pour abolir le réseau 5 g a
déjà été supprimé réfléchissez donc la
vaccination obligatoire est un business
et répond seulement à l'envi de se faire
bien voir des autorités l'état a besoin
d'une nation de débile la situation en
russie suscite des préocupations pavel
de rohff fondateur de maisons sociales
télégramme celui-là pas encore sous
l'emprise de google facebook a critiqué
les grands réseaux sociaux d'avoir
bloqué de fausses informations sur le
coronavirus selon de off c'est un moyen
efficace de lutter contre l'effet que
news
facebook twitter et d'autres plateformes
de réseaux sociaux ont bloqué les
publications mettant en avant la théorie
de la fuite d'un laboratoire
aujourd'hui en revanche cette théorie
est en train de devenir le point de vue
scientifique dominant sur les origines
du virus de telle qu à compliquer
singulièrement la lutte contre l'effet
que news et la désinformation dans son
ensemble ils peuvent aussi sapé
fondamentalement la confiance des gens
la neutralité des réseaux sociaux et
mettre en péril les futurs efforts de
lutte contre la désinformation
depuis 20 ans que je gère des
plateformes de discussion j'ai remarqué
que les théories du complot ne faisait
que se renforcer à partir du moment où
leur contenu était supprimé par les
modérateurs
au lieu de mettre fin aux idées erronées
la censure compliquer un peu plus la
lutte contre l c'est pourquoi la
propagation de la vérité sera toujours
une stratégie plus efficace que la
pratique de la censure facebook ou
télégramme
instagram ou twitter une chose est sûre
ce sont désormais les réseaux sociaux
qui décident de ce qu'on doit penser ou
pas